feels good to where I mean I thought the
game was pretty interesting you know I
won that rapid game and uh and I'm
Leuven for example but I mean that was
just that wasn't really much of a games
magnet just wandered a piece so to play
it play a complicated game and I mean
out lame and all the complications it
feels feels really good I guess
I'm also quite happy because some more
round move 40 I kind of messed it up I
mean when I when I played the see takes
up four move I think h6 just wins the
game I mean we don't even go on to the
second control so I'm quite happy that
even after I made the slight slip I was
still able to come back find the Queen
d1 Queen d4 idea and and convert so it's
it's quite nice but of course it's a
very long tournament and you know just
the start well I mean the thing is is
that it was very tricky because either I
have something that's straight forward
and winning our I have to do something
like exchange Queens or exchange Queens
or rooks in place and some really long
endgame or technically it's probably
winning but it's going to be extremely
difficult to convert so that was kind of
why I was looking everything a couple of
times but fortunately once I count Queen
Queen d1 Queen before I mean it's there
are there aren't many alternatives for
for white in the position so it wasn't
that hard to just keep looking at
everything few action times you know
there's there's a big difference I would
say between Magnus and a lot of the
other players in that if you tend to
play some some moves which are slightly
dubious you play some openings that are
a hundred percent solid or accurate you
can get in a lot of trouble and I've
found at least in my games against in
he's he's much better at punishing me
that
than some of the other players and so
what that does is that kind of it in it
makes it so that you have to adjust your
slightly it adjust the way that you play
and and like last year for example I
didn't really the operating play magnet
so when I'm playing some of these other
players and then then I play you know
got black ants magnets for example it's
very difficult because I just I didn't
have many opportunities to play more as
after Paris and lugan where I had the
chance to play what was like how many
times I can't doing that they think it
was six times total um six times or
whatever it was any times um it was it
was much easier kind of just getting the
mindset just just go with it so you know
it's it's it's very nice but again it's
one game it doesn't it doesn't mean that
much in the bigger scheme of things
you
and